[Music]
that's some of the work that I do is on
supersymmetry
so I've done a lot of work on the Higgs
boson and know generally I'm interested
in how to test new theoretical ideas and
right now I'm very interested in
gravitational waves of black holes and
so would you be able to describe what
supersymmetry theory is or what super
sevens with the symmetrical particles
could be so we have this theory of how
matter is built up out of elementary
particles things like the electron and
then the electrons form atoms because
they make clouds around nuclei and
inside the nucleus you have things
called protons and neutrons which are
not actually elementary particles
themselves they contain more elementary
things called quarks so these quarks
electrons those are the fundamental
constituents of matter so the theory of
supersymmetry postulates that in
addition to these particles which we've
already discovered there's a whole bunch
of what I would call sibling particles
which have the same internal properties
like for example electric charge so
there would be a supersymmetric partner
of the electron let's call it thus
electron which would have negative
charge just like the electron does but
there's a couple of very important
differences one is that it would weigh a
lot more much heavier mass and the other
thing is that it does not spin so all
the elementary particles that we know of
with one exception that I come back to
they all turn around on their axes at
about like spinning tops electron does
for example the photon the particle of
light that twists around as well but the
supersymmetric partner of the electron
would not and there would also be a
supersymmetric partner of the photon the
particle of light which would turn
around in a different way from
the photon does so as I said according
to supersymmetry all the known particles
have these sibling particles same
internal polishes same interactions if
you like about different maths and
different ways of spinning and why the
need to posit these super spherical
particles so the idea of supersymmetry
arose from attempts to try to unify all
the particles into a more more simple
picture and so supersymmetry was
originally suggested back in the 1970s
and then as time went on people thought
well actually you know that could be
useful for various things so example
supersymmetry could help us understand
why particles have the masses that they
do and why they don't weigh much more
for example the lightest supersymmetric
particle is probably stable and it could
be around us today in the universe some
sort of invisible dark matter particle
as we call it so little parentheses so
the astronomers the astrophysicists tell
us that in galaxies in addition to the
visible matter in stars there must be a
whole bunch of invisible stuff which
provides additional gravitational force
which holds the galaxies together and
that additional force could be produced
by these heavy supersymmetric particles
and so how do you go about doing this
research what evidence can you look for
so there's various different ways in
which you could look for supersymmetric
particles so you could imagine producing
them in laboratory experiment so one of
the things that we're doing in
experiments at CERN at the Large Hadron
Collider so there we bang protons
together at the highest possible
energies the highest possible rates and
look to see what comes out and it's
possible that pairs of supersymmetric
particles would come out or or more
generally pairs of dark matter particles
another way in which you could look the
supersymmetric particles is you know the
suggestion is that though these dark
matter particles flying around in the
galaxies all the time in particular
right here they're flat they're flying
past us and every once in a while one of
those dark matter particles will hit a
piece of regular matter and it will
leave behind some energy and so people
are designing very sensitive detectors
which can pick up this very small amount
of energy that's deposited when one of
these dark matter particles comes
through another thing which you can do
is well if there are these dark matter
particles flying around in our galaxy
every once in a while a pair of them may
collide and if they do then the energy
will be converted into regular particles
and then you can look for particular
types of conventional particles in the
cosmic rays to see whether there's any
evidence there of these annihilations of
these dark matter particles and do you
think that one of these experiments will
be more fruitful than others are you
working on all of these so I I'm working
on all of them at the same time because
these different experiments tell you
different things about where the
supersymmetric particles might be how
heavy they might be and how strongly
they can interact so it's interesting to
push in these various different
directions and eventually maybe by no
combining all these results then we may
get some better idea of what
supersymmetry looks like
and are we any nearer to understanding
what it looks like so far there's
there's no no real evidence of
supersymmetric particles there were some
hints
you know maybe supersymmetric particles
are just around the corner but right now
this there's no real solid evidence so
we just have to keep on doing the
experiments and maybe come up with more
creative ways of how to look for them
and what you be able to have to be able
to explain how this differs from the
standard standard model of physics how
this is sort of a radical change or if
it is or not this idea of supersymmetry
is a completely novel concept so a lot
of physics is based on the idea of
symmetry so supersymmetry means that you
try to relate together different
particles the way that they interact but
all the symmetries that we know about at
the moment interrelate particles that
spin in the same way and as far as we
can tell at the moment there are these
different types of particles of some
spin a little bit some spin some more
but we don't have any way of connecting
them directly together and that's where
supersymmetry comes in if you like it's
the it's the last frontier or the Wild
West of our search for symmetry and what
ramifications does this have for other
fields of like parts of cosmology such
as dark energy and dark matter
so supersymmetry could provide the Dark
Matter it might also help us understand
the amount of dark energy so dark energy
is some sort of distribution of energy
throughout empty space so dark matter
particles dark matter in general provide
gravity it holds galaxies together but
then if you look at the space between
galaxies it seems that there's some
energy out there which
feels gravity in a different way from
the particles that we know about this
was an idea that was suggested
originally by Einstein he called it the
cosmological constant and it's been kind
of a puzzle
ever since precisely because you can't
explain it in terms of conventional
particles seems to be a different sort
of substance if you like now one
question is you know whether it exists
at all and cosmologists discovered about
20 years ago that yes it does seem to
exist then the question is how big is it
and that's something we really have no
theoretical explanation for so because
want to just tell us how big but we
don't understand how it is that it has
that particular value but supersymmetry
could help us and what woods opponents
take up most with you about your theory
of supersymmetry what do they have issue
with well they would have issue was the
fact that we have no experimental
evidence for supersymmetry so they might
say yes it's a beautiful theory it's all
very nice but no where's the beef and I
have to say well so far there's no beef
and is the problem the theory or the
experiment so it could be that we just
need to do more precise experiments
collide particles at higher energies
make more collisions be more patient in
looking for the dark matter particles
flying around in the galaxies it could
be that we need to look at in a
different way so we used to some
particles being stable some particles
decaying very quickly maybe
supersymmetric particles at least some
of them would behave in an intermediate
way so they would not be completely
stable but they would take a long time
to decay and so that's something which
experiments at the CERN legend Large
Hadron Collider are thinking about
quite carefully now and other other
alternatives alternative theories which
could account for dark matter or as
supersymmetry sort of are only theory
out there so dark matter could be
explained by basically you know any type
of stable weakly interacting things that
you might imagine right
they shouldn't have electric charge
because then it would shine and it
wouldn't be dark so if they figured no
electric charge it has to have mass
because it has to generate a
gravitational field to hold the galaxies
together probably all its interactions a
weak it's even possible that the only
interaction that it has is gravitational
very very very weak interaction that
would be a bit of a bummer because then
it would be very difficult to find
direct experimental evidence Freud but
you know it's up to you if you can think
up some electrically neutral heavy
particle with fairly weak interactions
and you've got a Dark Matter candidate
and once you've proven if you prove that
there are super symmetrical particles
where would your research take you next
so supersymmetry as far as we can tell
is an essential feature of this theory
called string theory which is for my
mind the only serious candidate we have
for an all-encompassing theory of
everything so I think if we found
evidence for supersymmetry then the next
item on the agenda would be to try to
find some sort of positive evidence for
string theory one way or another but
that looks pretty tough how does string
theory provide a explanation of
everything
so string theory is a framework which
combines the force of gravity general
relativity with all the other
fundamental interactions that operate at
the level of elementary particles so
string theory can put gravity together
with electricity and magnetism for
example all the forces that exist inside
the nucleus and I just don't know of any
other theories that can do that and the
other thing about string theory is that
it provides a framework where you can
make a true quantum theory of gravity so
I think it's that no a great
embarrassment to theoretical physicists
that over a century after Einstein wrote
down the general theory of relativity
and since people developed quantum
mechanics we still are looking for a
theory that combines these two different
areas of physics it's a tough problem
but string theory provides a solution
and there's various indirect pieces of
evidence of that that's the right way to
go but we would really like to find some
more solid evidence in favor of string
theory and do you believe there is a
theory of everything
so we have to be very careful what do we
mean by a theory of everything so what
so what I mean by the phrase is a theory
of all the fundamental particles and
their interactions it's not a theory
that can explain Donald Trump okay that
is you know what in the language of
physics we would call an emergent
phenomenon which there is a different
type of problem altogether but I think
it is possible to imagine that there is
some unified theory at the fundamental
level which describes all the
fundamental constituents that make up
our universe and the forces between them
and is this or should this be the main
focus then bringing together quantum and
classical theories of physics so that is
I think the physicists Holy Grail that
is the objective towards which we should
be working it's not clear whether we can
find that Holy Grail you know anytime
soon I'm not sure whether I'll ever see
this theory of everything but I think
that is the objective towards which we
should be directing our efforts for more
debates talks and interviews subscribe
today to the Institute of Arts and ideas
at IAI TV
you